on this day in 1963 the very first
episode of Doctor Who aired in the UK an
unearthly child if you have never seen
it I highly recommend that you do so
even if you think you know everything
about Doctor Who this is legitimately
one of the best First episodes of the
Sci-Fi series ever it perfectly executes
its concept and draws you in with a
terrific sense of mystery great
production and wonderful performances if
you want to know more about what
happened behind the scenes there's a
dramatization of it with the film an
adventure in space and time time fun
thing that has gone on with that at the
very end of that minor spoiler there is
an appearance by the at the time current
doctor Matt Smith well in the most
recent airing and I believe as it is
currently showing on BBC I player you
now see shuy gatwa in that spot it has
actually been rumored that it was the
intention to update it with the more
current doctors as time went on they
haven't done it up to now but they've
done it here and I think it's a
wonderful way to celebrate the occasion
happy 60th doctor